bonjour denis perreault
oui merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu la loi et galim 2 vise à mieux
rémunérer les agriculteurs
elle arrive au sénat ce matin
rééquilibrer le rapport de force entre
les les fournisseurs et les
distributeurs à ce que cette fois ça va
marcher puisque la la première version
n'était pas satisfaisante
allez on est extrêmement dubitatif par
rapport aux ours qu'on peut espérer
cette loi qui comme vous le dites vient
en complément de la première sur
laquelle on avait exprimé nos réserves
et qui a bien montré que
qu'elles n'aboutissent à rien et
et dans celle ci on parle bien d'un
de l'obligation de tenir compte du coût
de production de lait dans les
négociations seulement on ne parle pas
du tout de la proportion de ce coût de
production et du coup on a une fois de
plus snif avait eu un coup d'épée dans
l'eau on connaît le rapport de force
entre les distributeurs et
au final les mais les producteurs et
on a l'impression qu'une fois de plus on
va passer à côté d'une autre pourrait
réellement améliorer notre la
rentabilité là le retour de la plus
value r les agriculteurs parce que la
loi lui dès l'hymne de promettait déjà
une meilleure rémunération pour les
agriculteurs qu'est ce qui changera
finalement avec et galine 2
il ya un point positif il ya déjà un
organisme public
de régulation des conflits de mètres de
vous de maîtrise des conflits donc ça
pour nous c'est plutôt une avancée après
mon pouvoir qu'est ce qu'elle raconte
pouvoir de
coercition mais pour le reste il n'y a
pas grand chose de plus
dans la loi il ya aucune contrainte il
ya la possibilité d'expérimenter le
éventuellement le tunnel de prix
nous qui était une revendication en
général porté par la confédération
paysanne mais qui dit une de prix dit
normalement
maîtrise de la production et régulations
l'âge et on voit bien comment une aile
de prix peut marcher sans envisager une
régulation de la production ya
le problème des marques distributeurs
les fameuses mdd qui représente dans
certaines productions et 30% des volumes
qui sont pour le moment exclues des
du ppe-de a plus d'obligation qu'il ya
dans cette loi donc
on a l'impression une fois de plus que
ça va est un coup d'épée dans l'eau donc
que le
je pense qu'il faudra qu'on revienne une
fois de plus sur sept
ce problème la rémunération des
agriculteurs qui j'étais a rappelé son
doivent être à peu près le seul corps de
l'éthique qui ne fixait pas lui-même ses
prix de vente le producteur ni ne fixe
pas ses prix dante les coûts de
production le tout les
les interprofessions ou les instituts
techniques les connaisse où on sait une
moyenne mais
si on faisait référence à ses coûts de
production en imposant une
queue leu leu
que leur que leur valeur soit voir
intégrer une part importante dans le
calcul des prix aurait peut-être moyen
de gagner quelque chose mais là j'ai
bien peur que ce soit
compromis il y aurait quand même ces
contrats écrits a priori qui rendrait
non négociable la la la part du du coup
de dé matières premières pour
l'agriculteur est ce que ça au moins
c'est une une bonne chose
ça pourrait être une bonne chose
la ferdi sous marins espagnols viennent
nous montrer que les contrats
sont quand même la signature n'engage
que celui qui en position de force il
faudrait plus de respect contraignant
pour
les fournisseurs et les distributeurs
il faudrait plus des aspects
contraignants on a du mal à imaginer que
les gagnants dans la sphère
fontanes aimant décide de partager avec
les clés etc et paysans qui sont plutôt
la variable d'ajustement avec une guerre
des prix qui est toujours
très acharnée entre les distributeurs
donc le
ont pensé lorsque s'il n'y a pas un peu
plus de contrainte ça va une nouvelle
fois on voit surtout le tour de la table
dans deux ans pour dire mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait merci beaucoup en tout cas
denis perreault d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire national de la confédération
paysanne